Bonjour à tous et à toutes !
Je viens de refaire le carrelage de ma salle de bain
avec des carreaux pentagonaux.
Oui, car j'adore les pentagones, sauf que...
En fait ça fait un carrelage avec des trous
(Ah tiens fais voir)
Voilà...
Tu aurais peut-être dû utiliser
d'autres formes de pentagones.
D'ailleurs le problème de carreler
sa salle de bain avec des pentagones,
c'est un sacré problème mathématique.
Et justement Michael Rao,
un informaticien théorique,
vient de mettre un terme à un siècle de
recherches mathématiques
sur la classification des pavages
mono-carreau par pentagones convexes.
Alors avant le théorème de Rao,
on connaissait déjà pas mal de carrelage par pentagones convexes
En 1918, le mathématicien Karl Reinhardt liste les cinq premières familles de pentagones qui pavent le plan.
Cinq, c'est déjà bien.
Sauf qu'en 1968, le mathématicien Richard Kershner ajoute trois nouvelles familles à cette liste.
Et il affirme avoir le stock complet.
(Y en a plus !)
Mais en 1975,
l'informaticien Richard James découvrit
une neuvième famille de pentagones.
Et ce n'est pas fini !
En 1977, Marjorie Rice, une femme au foyer sans formation mathématique,
humilie Kershner en découvrant
quatre nouvelles familles.
Et bing !
Et enfin en 2015, une quinzième famille de pentagones est découverte par le mathématicien Casey Mann
et ses collaborateurs.
Bon, y en a combien ?
On va continuer longtemps comme ça ?
Oui, c'est vrai que trouver de
nouvelles familles de pentagones, c'est cool,
mais ce qui est vraiment ambitieux,
difficile et satisfaisant,
c'est de toutes les trouver
et de prouver qu'on les a toutes.
Et c'est justement ce qu'a fait Michael Rao en mai 2017.
Le génie de Rao, c'est de ramener
un problème qui paraît infini
à un problème fini qui peut être résolu par un ordinateur.
Et c'est très surprenant quand vous y réfléchissez...
Le nombre de familles de
pentagones a priori c'est infini.
Et le nombre de façons de les arranger pour paver le plan, ça aussi a priori c'est infini.
Mais grâce à un premier logiciel, Rao a su identifier un ensemble fini de 371 familles candidates.
Il a démontré que pour tout pentagone
n'appartenant pas à ces familles,
il est impossible de paver un plan.
Attention, ça ne veut pas dire que ces 371 familles conviennent pour un pavage.
Juste que si un pentagone peut paver le plan,
alors il fait forcément partie de l'une d'elles.
Rao a ensuite développé un second logiciel
qui détermine lesquelles de ces 371 familles de pentagones pouvaient réellement paver le plan.
Bon, la mauvaise nouvelle, c'est que l'ordinateur
n'a pas trouvé d'autres familles de pentagones,
autre que celles qu'on connaissait déjà.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est que ceci prouve qu'il n'existe pas de nouvelles familles de pentagones.
D'où le théorème de Rao :
Un pentagone convexe pave le plan, si et seulement s'il appartient à l'une de ces quinze familles.
Bon, j'ai décidé d'utiliser des carreaux de formes différentes, voilà ...
Mais le pavage multiforme, c'est beaucoup trop complexe. J'peux plus t'aider.
Ben non !
Mais t'es vache, tu me laisses sur le carreau, là.
(Non je suis pas vache
"pas vache"... "pavage")
(Si t'es fier de ta salle de bain, abonne-toi)
(Et va voir Science4All)